et il a failli que faut-il retenir de ce
point presse alors beaucoup d'annoncés à
retenir de ce point presse qui a duré
comme vous l'avez dit une heure avec le
premier ministre qui a débuté cette
conférence en expliquant que le pays
était un conte est incontestablement
dans une phase de recrudescence de
l'épidémie le nombre d'hospitalisations
at-il dit commence à augmenter lentement
mais sûrement avant d'annoncer que 12 19
pardon nouveau département était en
rouge ce qui fait au total 21
départements en rouge et puis jean
castex a aussi annoncé que le port du
masque serait obligatoire dans tout
paris alors malgré cette évolution qui
est quand même inquiétante
le gouvernement veut à tout prix éviter
un nouveau confinement je propose
écoutez à ce propos le premier ministre
les principes qui nous guident la
logique globale transversale la
cohérence de notre action elle pourrait
se résumer en une phrase vivre avec le
virus
le virage est toujours là on vienne le
voir et même ils semblent progresser
nous devons donc nous doter de tous les
moyens pour stopper cette progression
est pour nous protéger et grâce à cette
protection à cette vigilance nous devons
nous devons tout simplement continuer au
maximum à vivre à travailler à nous
éduquer à nous cultiver à nous distraire
à vivre jean castex qui a d'ailleurs
annoncé des mesures économiques entre
autres le chômage partiel prolongé pour
les secteurs particulièrement touchés ou
encore des mesures est inédite pour
aider les jeunes c'est ensuite le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer qui a pris la parole
alors jean michel blanquer regret est
intransigeant inflexible sur la date de
la rentrée scolaire qui se tiendra bien
mardi prochain
les demandes de report des syndicats
d'enseignants ou encore de parents
d'élèves car dit-il l'école de la
république n'est pas une variable de la
crise sanitaire jean michel blanquer
ensuite rappelé les gestes sanitaires à
respecter pour accueillir les élèves
dans les meilleures conditions et qui a
rappelé que le port du masque serait
obligatoire pour tous les adultes et
pour les enfants de plus de 11 ans je
propose d'écouter
à ce propos le ministre de l'éducation
nationale il n'est pas prévu de mesures
d'ordre général concernant l'espace
scolaire dans les zones de circulation
plus active du virus mais nous pouvons
décider des mesures localisées c'est
isolement de la personne qui a des
symptômes remise de la liste des
personnes contactent à l' agence
régionale de santé dépistage rapide et
systématique des cas contactez analyse
de ces des résultats pour conduire les
autorités sanitaires préfectoral et
scolaire à envisager des mesures
éventuelle de fermeture
le fermeture temporaire d'une ou
plusieurs classes ou même d'un
établissement le cas échéant nous sommes
en mesure d'assurer la continuité
pédagogique d'un établissement ou d'une
classe que nous fermons par
l'enseignement à distance par la
distribution de matériel et par toute
une série de ressources pédagogiques
globalement pendant cette conférence de
presse l'exécutif avenue se montrer
combatif montré qu'ils étaient au front
et qu'il répondait aux critiques sur son
manque de clarté son manque de
lisibilité alors que les chiffres
continuent d'inquiéter
on a comptabilisé plus de 100000 4 son
nouveau call de kobe de ces dernières 24
heures soit le chiffre le plus élevé
depuis le maroc le mois d'avril quand on
était en plein coeur de la crise